- All right, gents,
now be tested in three tests.
Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your klewang will do, I
will take your klewang
and deliver slashes and thrusts
on these ballistics dummies.
Hunter, you're up first.
You ready?
Ready as I'm going to get.
My blade's very sharp.
I cut through probably half
a case of water bottles.
Took note of edge
defamation, and it's sharp,
so I just gotta hope it's
good enough for the dummies.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Hunter, let's talk
about your klewang right here.
Your edge over here is sharp.
It glides through
and lasts through it.
Your weapon, when
slashing, broke some ribs.
Your klewang, sir, will kill.
- Thank you.
All right, Tim, you ready?
As I'll ever be.
Hunter got really good feedback.
That first slice went in deep.
So he's got one mother
of an edge on that thing.
I hope mine does that well.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right,
Tim, the first thing
I noticed about is your handle.
The minute you
grab onto it, it's
ovoid enough to let us know
and index where the edge is.
You have a tip that's also
very sharp and pointed,
that when it penetrated,
it not only penetrated,
broke some ribs also.
Your klewang will kill.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Next
up, the strength test.
Bladesmiths, we've taken
these parts from a buffalo plow.
And to test the strength and
durability of your klewangs,
I am going to chop into them.
Remember, this test is all about
what they do to your klewang,
and not what your
klewangs do to them.
Hunter, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready as I'm going to get.
I'm really nervous.
My sword's lean,
it's pretty narrow.
This seems like it's going to be
a lot more brutal on the blades
than what I was expecting.
[music playing]
[bleep]
BEN ABBOTT: Well,
Hunter, your blade broke.
The main issue was that
at the intersection
of the blade and
this decorative curl,
there was a saw
cut that came in.
It's a sharp notch, and we
call those stress risers.
They're a place where
something is going to break.
The way you protect
against that problem
is you round the
bottom of that notch,
and it tends to dissipate
the energy better.
Hunter, your blade suffered
a catastrophic failure
and can no longer
continue with testing.
However, you're not out
of this competition yet.
Tim, your blade
also must survive
at least five whacks in order
for you to move forward.
TIM: Hunter's blade snapped.
(LAUGHING) Now I'm even
more nervous about what's
going to happen to mine.
[music playing]
BEN ABBOTT: Well,
Tim, it held up.
Can't see any evidence
of the activity
on the edge of this blade.
It's still razor-sharp.
I really enjoyed swinging it.
Nice job.
Thank you so much.
WIL WILLIS: Hunter,
your blade suffered
a catastrophic failure.
For that reason, I have to
dismiss you from the forge.
HUNTER: I'm feeling
pretty disappointed.
I don't know-- I just
thought it was going
to be more solid than that.
If I could start over
again, I'd make the blade
a little wider,
a little thicker,
and make sure to have
a stress point in it.
I still want to go full time.
I've definitely learned a lot.
Every blade I make from now
on is going to be better.